on soir hervé théry merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france avant le
président président un brésilien un vol
sonar au positif au coronavirus et c'est
le comble pour l'un des dirigeants les
plus corona sceptique sur la planète
non je crois pas je crois qu'il a
vraiment fait tout pour l'avoir refusé
d'appliquer les consignes il s'est réuni
avec des tas de gens au plus près il me
ferait tout ce qu'il fallait pas et il a
prouvé par l'absurde que les consignes
des bonnes alors oui enfin il à prouver
par l'absurde
effectivement mais enfin il a toujours
minimisé la pandémie l'a toujours re la
traîner des pieds pour faire appliquer
le confinement c'est quand même assez
cocasse ce qui se passe au brésil
aujourd'hui on se souvient aussi boris
johnson qui était un petit peu dans dans
le même temps et qui a aussi eu le
coronavirus que font-ils finalement
retenir comme le sont pour sept
dirigeants
boris johnson une fois qu'il l'a
attrapée est allé à l'hôpital il s'est
fait soigner il a rendu hommage aux
soignants pour bolton euros ça prend pas
ce matin la première chose qu'il a faite
en annonçant qu'ils étaient atteints
s'est retiré son masque pour parler aux
journalistes de plus près et il a dit
non j'ai eu 38 degrés et 38 degrés de
fièvre j'ai pris litres d'eau croquis du
tout va bien donc il prend pas du tout
chemin du repentir semble-t-il
alors effectivement il dit recevoir un
traitement à l'hydroxyethyl au rock
indie allait parfaitement bien on
rappelle que ce traitement était
extrêmement critique et d'ailleurs voilà
rejeter entre guillemets par par l' oms
comme un traitement valable que doit-on
effectivement retenir aussi de cette
séquence n'est pas rien quand un
dirigeant affirme se soigner avec une
molécule et qu'il dit allait
parfaitement bien c'est une forme de
renard 2
de provocation par rapport à l'om est
notamment de défis il est vraiment dans
le déni et dans le défi fait partie des
six pays au monde qui sont dans le déni
il ya trois baies ya le burundi le
brésil et la ville russie le nicaragua
et j'en oublie deux autres n'y a que six
pays au monde qui font ça et il est
dedans et donc il est un des livres mais
aussi appelé ça le club des autruches
c'est à dire expliquez-nous ça veut dire
quoi apprendre ministre on y croit
vraiment qu'on fait semblant pas y
croire on fait comme les autruches ce
conte ce qu'on dit des autruches en tout
cas s'il ya qu'elle enfonce leur tête
dans le sable en espérant être protégés
ils assez discrètement le refus de
prendre en compte la couse la réalité et
vous avez raison ce serait cocasse c'est
cocasse où ce serait cocasse il n'y
avait pas plusieurs deuxièmes dizaines
de milliers de morts à la clé il ya
vraiment beaucoup de gens qui vont en
mourir
de fait que ont tiré à hue et à dia le
gouvernement fédéral sous sa direction
ni il a déjà joué deux fois son
ministère de la santé alors que les
gouverneurs des états et les gouverneurs
de ville essaie de faire respecter le le
confinement d'ombré dans un pays comme
la france où c'est à peu près
coordonnées ya quand même des
cafouillages imaginer que les présidents
des régions les présidents département
et le ministère de la santé dit des
choses différentes à la population
serait complètement perdu alors on voit
au moment vous nous parler ces images
effectivement de funérailles
d'enterrement au brésil ces enterrements
entre guillemets de masse vingt mille
nouveaux cas
en 24 heures on a du mal quand même à
penser que ce que les brésiliens ne se
révolte pas devant un président qui
continue est dans un déni que vous venez
de nous décrire et les morts qui qui
continuent d'affluer
tous les jours quelle est la réaction
des brésiliens la majorité dans tous les
sondages disent qu'ils sont absolument
convaincus qu'il faut rester confiné ce
qu'on entend le plus c'est la minorité
de 25 5% des partisans inconditionnels
de boxe au now qui font du bruit des
manifestations mais dans mes collègues
dans mes amis dans ma belle famille
les gens restent confinés ils sont pas
fous et donc ce qu'on voit le plus c'est
le sait là les gens qui défient et puis
d'autre part les gens pauvres qui n'ont
pas le choix qui doivent sortir tous les
jours pour gagner de quoi se nourrir et
nourrir leurs enfants et donc ne peuvent
absolument pas appliquer le confinement
dans tous les gens qui sont dans la rue
sont pas là par des fils y en a qui sont
là par défi aujourd'hui l'om est ce pas
revancharde finalement souhaite un
rapide rétablissement à bâle sonar ou
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
voilà enfin seront faits de la fiction
ici peut-être mais si sa maladie
s'aggraver il pourrait peut-être
retrouver la voix de la raison et
changer sa vision justement sur la
maladie et surtout sur sa gestion de la
crise a jugé par ses premières réactions
pas tellement que je lisais attendant un
éditorial du principal journal brésilien
qui s'appelle la follia feuilles de
saint paul est un des chroniqueurs
disait ce que le président réélu à faire
pour de l'aisance et de mourir du coc
vide je souhaite vivement qu'il meurt
quand on en est là c'est vraiment qu'il
est très forte radicalisation
oui effectivement sao paulo où vous êtes
est en train de se décomposer c'est bien
ça ça veut dire qu'il ya quand même des
régions du brésil où où la situation
s'améliore forcément c'est enfin
apparemment elles sont paul le pic est
en train de passer mais le virus se
répand vers l'intérieur donc des régions
qui étaient jusque là protégé sont
atteintes mais à saint paul il ya donc
20 millions d'habitants dont quatre
millions et demi dans les régions les
plus pauvres de la zone est et non pas
le choix qu'ils ont jamais respecté le
confinement merci à hervé théry docteur
en géographie professeur à l'université
de sao paulo d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france